autre note comme arena quotidienne on va
commencer à 13h20 tranquille où j'ai
créé le tournoi j'attends vous inscrire
et petit à petit je voulais c'est arrivé
aussi dans le tchat
je vois déjà quelques habituels qui sont
déjà inscrits créée en découdre calage
qu'on a toujours pas vu jouer la kalach
on attend impatiemment la hongrie de la
que le spécialiste du blackmar edinson
cavani toujours au chômage technique
avec le psg
il a tous les jours aussi les fidèles
alors je balançais le lien déjà si
certains d'entre vous sont dans le chat
et arrivent petit à petit j'ai mis des
partis en font mais je conserverai pas
vraiment apte à commenter des joueurs
aussi forts on état actuel des choses
parce que je suis bien bon direct
l'instant le doute est permis
ce qui avec 1
peut se manifester ça m'arrangerait
voilà ça fait plaisir
haga qui est là salut taga je veux doute
de la technique maintenant a priori tout
fonctionne bien saluerait nous
aujourd'hui on voit jouer en 3 + 2 et
salue baron fou alors pour ceux qui sont
déjà là est-ce que vous avez un petit
peu suivi hier cette grosse soirée au
profit de médecins sans frontières
est-ce que vous en avez pensé moi j'ai à
peine pu regarder l je n'ai vu que m m's
elle s'était fait plaisir mais pas trop
peiné gagner en troll en tout cas plus
de 100000 pas vous montez les colts et
vraiment je vous l'aurais dire un gros
merci à tous de ultra généreux
ça dépasse nos attentes on espère que ça
continuera ce soir vous êtes déjà
quelques-uns dans l'arène
est ce que le fait qu'on soit dimanche
comme ce que votre vie ou pas du tout ce
que dimanche est devenu mardi pour vous
bah oui
petit jour un russe et un indien gupta
pour l'instant un petit peu moins de
monde que d'habitude mais en quelques
13h04 soyons patients
je ne me réveille avec vous j'ai pas
faire semblant de commenter cette partie
1 si vous avez déjà quelques questions
n'hésitez pas sur n'importe quoi
d'ailleurs
voilà
ce soir je crois que c'est à 20h30
mais mais l'antenne sera prise dès dès
19h voire avant je crois que cav et
femmes feront quelques parties à la paix
trilogiq a un peu chauffé le terrain
tranquillement salut qu'à kalach
quelques calages donc qui étaient là
pour concurrencer kaka onctueux je ne
m'abuse la dernière fois on espère les
retrouver
je vais éviter de penser avant demain
jour du cours berriat encore encore et
toujours taillés en même temps si
l'épisode aux crêtes plus poétique
je m'adapterai ou et par les revers sera
un petit peu compliqué aujourd'hui ne
vous le cache pas ça reste jouable avec
un peu d'inspiration depuis que je
commente kinkala j'arrête de manger mais
si on voit que le nombre de pions n'est
pas très important ce qui compte c'est
de courir plus vite de plus avancé peut
faire d'amis si récupérer la tour
tranquillement infernale qui choisit pas
le moyen le plus courant d'aller à dame
mais ok maintenant ceci dit les trois
pions pas s'allier à beaucoup trop
compliqué ça je pense qu'on les a assez
facilement sur tomates le roi ok ok ok
ce qu'on va réussir à atteindre les 100
aujourd'hui
rien n'est moins sûr instant je ne vois
pas les verts je suis inquiet ni maugrée
fallen a raté une édition depuis le
début peut-être que c'est le repas
dominical je ne sais pas aux familles je
pense conserver un petit peu vous
tradition en cette période spéciale
salle paquito hockey tant mieux c'est
une bonne nouvelle
et hier soir vous n'avez pas dû suivre
du coup forcément parce que vous étiez
focaliser sur maxime et consorts est lui
aussi le chemin de france online des
clubs qui s'élançait et quelle vie
comprendre quand même de temps en temps
les arénas homme qui peut alterner parce
que il ya quand même beaucoup beaucoup
de stream du coup renault c'est un peu
difficile de faire ça tous les jours
surtout un instrument aussi le soir et
la semaine prochaine d'aia il y aura fab
il sera de retour un petit peu salut
perceval et il va vous paquito je vous
l'été général hier et on aura aussi une
invitée de marque la semaine prochaine
maïs vague qui nous fera l'honneur de
commenter avec nous la meilleure joueuse
française
je compte sur vous pour être présent au
rendez vous ne pas manquer lui posais
plein de questions pense que ce sera
assez sympathique s'allume au greffe
aulaye
je sens que se trouve serait joué à
cette perspective dans le chat du
on refera quelques hommes là j'ai pu te
vois ça y est on refera quelques durant
la semaine prochaine ça lui dit 65
ok tu laisses la chance aux autres du
coup maugrée soleil c'est bien de temps
en temps merci ouais on refera quelques
duos puisque c'est vrai que cette
semaine je crois qu'on était tout le
temps au solo à tour de rôle avec avec
quelle et du coup on appelle les grands
maîtres en renfort voir un petit peu
varié les plaisirs changer de rythme va
commencer dans une dizaine de minutes
c'est soit que c'est super agréable de
voir maxime en plus les hyper naturel au
delà du fait qu'il soit évidemment
extrêmement extrêmement fort il est très
disponible
d'ailleurs ce soir si vous avez vu il
donnera une interview après sa probable
victoire contre souffre
voilà je ne tenais pas moins de toi
taïga après sa probante victoire comme
son second dans etienne bacrot il
reviendra sur son expérience de la
première moitié des candidats maxime
compagnie qu'elle vienne pourrez poser
toutes vos questions
je pense que sa part un petit peu
discuté cuisine mais on va quand même le
droit d'en savoir plus sur comment ça se
passait en russie un petit peu spécial a
priori les maxima réussi à tirer son
épingle du jeu
pour l'instant on a une aide qui le plus
fort élan d'inscrits qui hélas souvent
lucide
du coup le fait qu'on soit dimanche vous
envoûter complètement où vous faites des
trucs un peu différent ouais c'est
exactement ça paquito ne joue pas un
rôle et la carte par fermant
parfaitement le naturel maxime parmi les
tops gm je pense que c'est certainement
l'un des plus accessibles
là il est très apprécié dans le circuit
même parmi ses congénères
je pense que tout le monde s'entend bien
avec maxime tout le monde aime bien
maxime ouais ok paquito je vis au jour
le jour là comme beaucoup je pense en ce
moment donc on bascule pas pour le mode
vivre au mois le mois
ça reste ok je pense qu'on a encore
peut-être une trentaine de jours comme
ça petit à petit espérons que la
situation se décante on une finale pas
90 comme vous pouvez le voir avec trois
pions contre eux une paire de fous
complètement stérile des sites bloqués à
des choses plus graves trois dons qui se
voulait vouloir faire hkd
dans tous les cas le matériel est trop
élevé pour espérer gagner non valable
après je vois au chaos donc un petit
flag est toujours pris avec les
jamais se permettre de manger ce
cavalier si nous basculerons foot
couleurs opposées synonyme de mule
assurent elles les progrès sont un petit
peu il met la pression
gardez le pew alors là ntp lalalalalala
ciron batala lalande qui s'est inscrit
deuxième élan j'avais jamais vu la manyu
guignard carte habituelle parmi les ont
créés il a tous les jours
salut marques ou des premiers
effectivement paquito c'est aussi dans
ce genre de situation on se rend compte
sur qui on peut compter
salut qu eric salut manu ouais c'est de
suivre un peu de thé party aujourd'hui
sont mettre la pression
cette fois-ci ou de poids c'est ça
arrive à un certain nombre de fois
il salue jiao gang robe faire
plus le son on sait j'espère surtout que
ça doit venir de toi marques ou des
premiers parce que si vous devez lire
sur mes lèvres pendant l'intégralité du
stream
ça s'annonce compliqué salut launch s
salut grid carmine frog grenouille verte
je suis bilingue pour le sony
aujourd'hui je pense que je pourrais
apprendre de chaque troll au premier
degré par souci de transparence je vous
annonce que la la nuit fut courte donc
mes calculs de variantes seront
peut-être un petit peu moins affûté
habituellement ok tant mieux pour le son
maintenant je ne joue pas je pense que
ce serait distribution est lourd
générale sur laquelle 13 soldats tombés
contre moi c'est pas grave tout entier
je laisse la chance aux autres c'est
bien c'est fait à part ok ok donnez
donnez donnez moi ouais je pense que je
pourrai refaire le clip la d'abricots
sur fond de parties d'échecs son
problème joyeux réveil marconnet et je
compatis à la douleur et à tes futurs
les actes de générosité tu restes dans
l'esprit et de la soirée d'hier c'est
bien alors on stars dans cinq minutes
un peu moins nombreux mais hoguet
l'haletant tactile vrai cocktail en
vidéoconférence je viens ici seulement
j'aurais aimé soirée organisation soirée
problèmes techniques
ces demoiselles plan tient le lien h le
monde des matelas tardive c'est à cette
politique bakhit où j'aime bien je veux
bien candidate et j'ai accepté je vois
d'un script et l chara petite chaîne de
poésie paquito ce que là
vu la conjoncture at inspire quel genre
de poésie écriture n'hésite pas à mettre
le lien dans le chat en cette ve vous
partagez des talents un intéressant
le robot aime pas qu on partage de
livres qui n'ont rien à voir je ne sais
pas trop texpos eddy ressenti du coup tu
as un blog chaîne ça se passe comment tu
peux nous partager les élans inspiré ou
non d'ailleurs supermen mais je ne doute
pas de condat long du couloir a baladés
à sensible à quel point c'est bien
décrire d'ailleurs dans des choses sur
deux sujets qui touchent
si nous impacte pas j'ai déclenché
l'émotion un petit peu l'essence même de
la poésie
alors qu'ici nous déclenche une émotion
à notre ami indien à savoir la détresse
chez le joueur russe
je fais complètement ouvrir son roi ac
c'est le gruyère blanc vous êtes en
train de manger sain possible je
souhaite un bon appétit rangement ça se
fait bien le féminisme primaire de se
faire des ennemis à adam ce chat
malheureusement d'ailleurs je crois que
ça me manque un petit peu de filles
chose qui te touche saganash est ce que
j'ai peur de comprendre ou pas mais oui
je les mets ton expression de matelas
tardif effectivement paquito une jolie
formule pour définir les noctambules
alors le tournoi va commencer
c'est une petite minute
y aurait-il des poètes en particulier
kaka lâche des lieux jusque d'autres
saluent xy là qui bat comme annoncé
c'est très bien passé on l'a réussi ici
mais on va se concentrer sur la haine
est-ce que c'est parti dans vingt
secondes alors on va commencer par
regarder les numéros 1 puis après je
regarde un petit peu tout le monde
pour l'instant c'est l'ined mdp
lalalalalala haut careï qui vont
s'affronter
bonne chance à tous
on aurait bien besoin
allez c'est parti alors j'aime beaucoup
les noirs déjà il a mis son foncia glk
et au delà tout compris vise la grande
diagonale mais ici on a un petit peu un
système de londres avec les blancs du
cas ça y ressemble quelque chose de très
solides
un peuple autres à mon goût mais les
voyons voir comment ça se poursuit des
fois on peut jouer avec h 400 avoir
bloqué être le fou un peu plus manière
plus ambitieuse en d3 mais ça reste
difficile pour les pour les noirs ce qui
est bien généralement c'est d'essayer de
choper se [ __ ] casselois je pense que
h3 ce doyen est requis dont jean
d'ouverture et essayez de manger le
fouquet alors là il ya ces drones dont
jacques poux normalement ce qui est
standard ici c'est comme de jouer à age
3 ha bon la part des plans
être à vendre hockey veut à tout prix
garder ce fou parce que c'est lui qui
pose des problèmes dans cette diagonale
du coup je pense que je joue un petit
peu trop vite ont lutté lalalalala mais
rien de dramatique mais le noir ou
plutôt l'avantagent la paire de fous
plus d espace le centre même si des 5
peut se retrouver un tantinet faible il
va pouvoir le défendre
la m le français 6 ogier va s'enlever de
ce visage et dans la colonne des et pour
les planches que ça c'est dur de trouver
un plan ici peut-être échanger les fous
de cases blanches mais pas une bonne
idée pour ensuite gagner la case est
simple pour le cavalier ça c'est dans le
cas où tout se passe très bien où je
rongeais 4 et noir je pense devront
lutter contre ça mais c'est pas si
facile maintenant que le pion des 5e se
retrouve affaibli et tient le lien
supporter à tricolore bon la présence et
six au moins permet de consolider un peu
le centre pour les noirs et des petites
faiblesses
la position est assez assez équilibré
qui est des chances des deux côtés je
dirai combien c'est quand même pas si
j'aurai plutôt ramener madame oms et 2 à
mot le but c'est d'amener un cavalier en
bref ça qui ne commencerait bien et que
les plans c'est pas facile à trouver le
chemin
c'est un peu le chemin de croix pour
l'instant l'été gourmand mais ok le
pioneer perdu la tour s'activant
sexuelle second projet les 4 b 4 c'est
bien joué c'était sûrement sur le coup
ici est-ce qu'on peut manger ces trois
plongées c5 est on va avoir des
problèmes dans cette colonne si la dame
veut se défaire du cloud h jusqu'au
crime c6 qui va tomber le pion des 5
ensuite ce qui se passe et comment il a
réagi et s'est passé exactement ça mais
don de prémonition en action donc
qu'est-ce qu'on cluj fou ça a l'air
d'être le bon cours est peut-être un peu
peur d'affaiblir eve 2 mais pas très
grave la du malade d une deuxième pièce
doit pour attaquer il ya du tout procès
3 c'est le saoût aux yeux malgré malgré
tout la conne je pense que tactiquement
la joie un peu vite c'est dommage parce
qu'on sent qu'il ya une surcharge de
cette dame là regarde deux endroits à la
fois je sais pas peut-être la petite de
faire des puzzles rush mais le tour
prend ses trois essais juste gagné une
pièce de secours et la partie donc c'est
une belle opportunité de rater pour la
la la la la
il est quand même mieux il a réussi à
manger ses six battant le canadien a une
belle occasion des quatre ans rejoindre
f5
je suis tellement c'est un peu difficile
ici pour les noirs ça reste pas
dramatique
et oui jean vous ne la doudoune je
revendique ce titre de devin je vais
essayer d'en être digne par la suite
alors ici l'idée était clairement leur
tour ces huit ans poser des problèmes
sur la vie de se venger
voilà encore une fois la rabine à toi
l'avant je dois être à cette fois au
truc casse maymou la jeunesse va déjà
essayer sont pas forcément d'intérêt
ultime et on a entendu un bruit de
propositions nul c'est pas beau je sais
pas qui a osé commettre ce sacrilège
céline est donc les brouilles et moi
bien donc l'a fait sans semble
évidemment on était là là là là là même
pas les citer un quart de seconde
mais le problème c'est que c'est une
décision stratégique semble douteuse de
manger de renforcer ce pion qui étaient
isolés vers la case est simple pour le
cavalier du coup atteint et je trouve
que d'hab on aucun des forces moins bien
donc peut-être anecdotiquement mieux cd4
qui se retrouvaient faible
le roi est un peu plus avancé après y'a
pas de chemin
donc cette première partie devrait se
solder par une nulle le spectaculaire
appartement de fonction des saisons
jamais alors là ouais j'aurais pas
échanger les tours non plus par contre
ou alors il ya un truc est très jolie
liam attendant g3 qui est imparable en
fait je vois pas de coût qu'une fin
tragi comique si les maîtres sont rois
en f4 n'importe quel autre cas c'était
nul
et après le simple roi f2 je veux bien
en face de toi je te regarde dans les
yeux et je te dis hémato prochain là
c'est un petit peu le gag
cette fin de partie en fait je fais
semblant de commenter j'ai exactement je
joue tous les coups
m
pour cette première partie est rigolo de
terminer là dessus sur ce petit matin je
pense que ined apprécié - a priori alona
barbarian qui s'est inscrit à marianne
qu'à l'habitude de d'enchaîner les
points dans ces arènes va s'intéresser à
cala chez skil a joué une kalach cas là
je n'arrive pas tous les jours
jours une partie de calage souayah les
blancs soit son adversaire qui joue des
cas du coup il me rend mal j'ai joué mon
ouverture si j'ose me l'approprier j'ai
six couches et 7,6 et on va revenir au
direct et kalach même s'il a ajoué de
kalach c'est plutôt très très bien passé
on n'a même pas eu le temps de voir
il a même ignoré la had a nommé madame
il ne la prend pas je suis beaucoup trop
fort à faire car une autre fourchette
le ca de le retrouver peut-être du début
à l'épaule et une partie qui vient de
commencer entre ba et me bouge pour la
victime de ganache et un charlatan genre
encore des bruits de propositions nul
dans l'ouverture annoncée bas de la vie
me signale qu'un écran 20 de volée par
la fenêtre
c'est bien possible peut-être juste une
souris ça reste une partie d'échecs
je pense que ici cat et sa souris les
plus raisonnables que l'écran dans ce
cas précis parfois le rythme avec écran
du coup à une position intéressante avec
je vérifie connaît bien égalité
matérielle il s'est rien passé de
dramatique avec les blancs qui on voit
qu'ils envoient les pions au centre on
leur fait plutôt au contrôle ici il ya
ce but aly dans la colonne c est
notamment qui pourrait être embêtant
alors la prison ainsi su que j'allais
dire j'ai pas trop compris maintenant
oui merci merci de m'expliquer bibou des
coûts pour faire une enfilade
moi j'étais plutôt tenté par mon gestion
sur échec quand même à la base ennemie
bout qui retarde la prise de la tour en
battant va pouvoir - gt5 est classé ça
se passe pas bien pour charlatans peut
tous faire manger injuste on mange le
fou et
qui ont l'air aussi cavalière s'est fait
ça se passe très mal at on peut manger
mais cette attaque la tour et menace une
découverte c'est pas grave si on veut se
venger les cavaliers gagner une tour des
champs juste d'approuver cette alerte
récente cahier prend le soin qui est
très bon aussi comment on peut
13.2 ragonneau d'austra d'amis c'est un
peu comme ça on sache qu'on fouille bain
pour avoir 13 points à vos plantes et
des maths du berger je pense ou avoir
des adversaires très qu'on s'entend
presque envie de rina mm ou pseudo
chasse comme en australie
à 70 ans et l'abandonné charlatan un
petit peu dépité savait qu'il était
foutu après il aurait pu se battre comme
je trouve que là c'est un petit peu un
petit peu coire de sa part à la manu
guignard n'arrive juste pour la fin
d'une belle finale de foot couleur
opposée avec égalité deux pions mais qui
est perdante c'est pas de chance
souvent ou pas voire deux pour moi vous
de que reposent les stars nul et bien si
ces trois contre trois mais c'est foutu
c'est foutu parce que le fou bas il va
juste se faire manger par le roi et il
est trop appartient aventure avec son
droit malheureusement là il n'y a pas
d'issue pour manu est vraiment tout
simple il suffit de cartables et d'aller
manger les pions donc thimote timothée
timothy ne sait pas tout cas il va
gagner facilement va chercher autre
chose mais c'est déjà bien à la fin on a
paquito peut-être pas qu'eto'o entre
citron chocolat citron chocolat et ce
qui nous parle de glace ici j'aurais
bien envie d'une glace mais il commence
à faire super beau après citron chocolat
est ce que c'est un mariage des saveurs
très près ce qui je sais pas ça va pas
très bien ensemble
ces canadiens même assez dommage le
futur oui si on a tous fous avec deux
pions donc paquito à quito qui se fait
plaisir avec les noirs au chocolat il
essaie de se battre mais je crains pour
lui que ce ne soit vain ici pas de place
aux maths ni de perpète ont plus le fou
contrôler toutes les cases
je serai plus à l'heure où ces deux pour
essayer de menaces et chaque à l'infini
mais allez peut-être maintenant pour ces
deux airois g3 m'écoute pas mais coûte
passeront chocolat non content
divergent sur nos choix de parfums
ongles à ce mot divergent aussi sur nos
coûts aux échecs
c'est assez logique une corrélation
entre les deux ça y est il y arrive t'on
ce club où il suffit de faire un échec
alors là ce qui pourrait être dramatique
et rigolo si on reste dans le thème des
maths et des c'est ça je ne souhaite pas
de mal comme ça à paquito watch 3 y
réfléchir en fait il suffit juste
d'attendre que les noirs face échec pour
m la tour devant citron chocolat faut
avoir une perte de goût pour bouffer ça
peut-être être le corps au-delà du coup
parce que je crois que c'est un des
symptômes malheureusement on perd un peu
l'odorat du confort c'est bon le goût
j'espère que citron chocolat au moins du
choix du pseudo avec ce n'était pas trop
récent tout cas la création de son
compte
on va s'inquiéter pour sa santé
il suffit d'envoyer le pion maintenant
des cats bien ce encore plus précis ah
non pas du tout je retire ce que je
viens de dire mais ok ça reste un petit
peu de technique galère un petit peu
inquiétant quand même je vais pas
critiquer mais c'est quoi une trentaine
de coups et une pièce de plus au point
que ali qui propose nul ici je sais pas
j'ai en tant que l'animation monde
imagine que c'est forcément citron
c'était bien sûr refusé mais mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe il va réussir à
ne pas perdre je ne comprends plus rien
au monde ce que tu as réussi à arriver
jusqu'aux f2 c'est assez mystérieux
ça devient ça devient critique en fait
pour les blancs j'ai gagné parce qu'il
va y avoir mais qu'est-ce qu'il a fait
là voilà là alors c'est rouge coco là
ils pouvaient pas juste je vais te
trompes et deux pour arrêter le clou
puisque l'idée c'est juste que la tour
blanche en fait et force est ce qu'à
fait sacrifier sur ce plan le fou est
juste papa où il faut donc si on veut
tourbe et de ici il va se passer quelque
chose comme saddam et ça va faire du
loup quoi il aurait pu sauver citron
chocolat dont média peut être
miraculeuse juste tombé 2 où il a raté
paquito la bête et drian techniquement
dans cette partie salut au grand maître
gims est on
pour position atypique entre la
grenouille verte les 10 65
je vais essayer de deuxième dame alors
son adversaire qu'on n'a même plus à
hyper sympathique d'à peine cinq dames
c4 rien peut tout gagner ici pour les
blancs sans le champion ne serait pas la
même histoire mais mais là il va
justement géraud suite même gagné la
tour avec dams et 3 c'est pas grave il
va la gagner le coup d'après toute façon
d'une façon ou d'une autre conte à tour
est très éloigné du roi comme certains
assez facile de finir par faire au
double échec
un peu des deux voilà la grenouille
impressionnante ici et affamés
apparemment et du coup dit d'abord donne
ok alors
comment juste parfait entre toutes sur
dur et dragons ne sais pas quelle nature
exactement je ne le dirai pas un mélange
d'espagnol d'italien de zombies evans
dont je sais pas
je sais que ça existe a chuté déjà vu il
ya eu des 5 sep de mal se passer comme
pour les noirs souvent à manger ce point
4 d'un peu présent tu es ici et si la
mort est là ok alors que je pense que
fout des trois valeurs prometteur en
disant vas tu t'attaques de chevaux d'un
coup ils peuvent pas se défendre dans
l'autre donc du coup ça gagner un cheval
gayic valade je sais très fort au qui
l'a pas vu il a pas vus et finalement
tout est bien qui finit bien pour draco
n'en a pas perdu de pièces quand même
grattez un pion un tueur au passage
qu'elle a plein de fougue a fini son
développement et à dessein douleur quand
même qu'ils mangent le cavalier doit
jouer sont les noirs finalement qui
émerge très bien de cette ouverture de
passes pop et les personnes utilisant un
ordi bas il ya déjà des patchs et scame
il ya des choses qui sont sont mises en
oeuvre pour détecter les tricheurs façon
de temps en temps ça peut vous arriver
peut-être de recevoir même mais là vous
avez récupéré dix points parce qu on a
remarqué que vous avez perdu une partie
contre un tricheur salue le sourire de
kitano et ça lui qui arrive alors ça
de mal en pis on reporte culture qui
fait fi de toutes les recommandations
structurelles au niveau des pions à
savoir se trouve avec 5,5 gillot donc
façon c'est très solide à 2 x 3 doit
faire environ 6 et du coup ça donne un
bon avantage au noir il a rappelé en
plus meilleures structures hors pas plus
à l'abri des pièces plus actifs donc le
tout mis bout à bout ça aura trille or
il attache de tutures ardue donc avisés
à talbissé 3
dragon's haut et je vous de manière très
concrète identifie les faiblesses et il
est attaque vous encourage à faire la
même chose
justin van der kamp on sait à se faire
un petit abri pour le roi au cas où on
arrive aux maths du coup arrive tard il
est là on va simplement mon giro
on a deux y'a pas de tour 7 a profité de
l'abandon de la 8ème rouget et
maintenant ça fait deux points de plus
et dragotto qu'une affaire de technique
j'aimerais bien voir un callas contre
gaga lâche voir lequel des deux est le
vrai va quand même laisser les ses
dragons va essayer de terminer sa partie
vous étaler sa technique c'est
questions n'hésitez pas pelé c'est je
pense un peu dragon's en autonomie ici
aussi lui faire confiance
surtout rue vite on va juste bouger à
tour est vite x fi 2 c'est pas trés de
rejoindre le roi il paye en achète toute
façon tant qu'on a notre fou de cases
noires avec les noirs ou n'est pas
inquiet d'une attaque éventuelle
là on se dit que la rate et mme
attendant peut-être que j'ai pas peur je
vois pas quand a ici ah bah oui
je parlais je regarde le chat j'ai pas
vu alors il ya eu des cistes g6 au lieu
de 2,6 soit choc très bien vieux ggg
jadis c'est assez incroyable s'ils ont
raté les deux joueurs ce thème est assez
évident quand même près encore une fois
c'est du blitz précipite étude sur qui
va être déçu et que je ne le connais pas
on se rendre compte de cela si nous
écoute c'est dolly là une belle
opportunité en plus il n'a pas encore
perdu mais derrière derrière ça se passe
pas bien il a perdu on fout une sphère
où âgé de trois ans peut manger le faux
ici obama tu es le roi g5
on peut faire comme tout à l'heure un
truc jolly wager cette nacelle si ce
matin par able à l'image du mat de la
première partie assez vu derrière
parlera aguado à toi
ça provoque l'abandon turc a donc raté
quand même un bâton deux c'est dommage
c'est bien dommage
on a la grève des chèques
greg d'échec oui entre manu manuka une
dame de moi j'étais pas je suis déjà
arrivé sur les parties de manille où ça
se passe bien pour lui
désolé de dire ça vient ça se passe bas
ça se passe par au fait
voilà ils voulaient pas qu'on vienne le
voir je vais arrêter du coup j'ai arrêté
de l'espionné alors nadi dix neuf 19
contrats rejet lol et deux joueurs ont
échangé les dames
à notre plus grand regret ils sont joués
1 berlin savais pas que des gens jouer
le berlingo blitz ici c'est plutôt reste
gravé dans un mois a great show mvl
compagnie pour les candidats mais là des
experts théoricien mais je dois vraiment
de porter la poisse manioc après le mal
était déjà fait quand tu arrives et une
cité un petit peu le feu d'artifice avec
eux avec la double enfilade dans la
diagonale noir avaient déjà été déjà
leur bar a priori puisque tu fais c'est
que quand tu es complètement gaillon
avant à têtu mais un mois dans le tchat
j'allais voir ta partie aux jurés le
sort a voulu faire le beau jeu quoi
paraît qu'on pensait pas récompensé
alors ça donne quoi cette période à des
fous très actif ici avec les noirs mais
assez standard pour cette ouverture ils
déploieront leur zèle plus tard les
blancs jouissent d'un gros avantage des
espaces mais c'est pas si grave
je pense que c'est ça qui est un bon
coup on se donnait des cases pour nos
pièces et empêcher justement les plans
de eux-mêmes jouer ces cinq là mais ça
nous laisserait lagaf' des cinq ceci dit
vaut quand même réagir à bourdonner
voilà dix neuf qui nous écoutent et un
petit lac quand même un petit décalage
ne peut pas non plus profité de mes
conseils parfois avisé 31 paraît assez
logique
j'aimerais bien rentrer en dix huit avec
les bancs en a 3 pourra quand même
revenir couvrir d'autres cavaliers
d'ailleurs voté ce qu'en dit style mnl
guignard je viens voir ce que c'est le
potez gros beats les touristes et aux du
coup ce possible tiens c'est peu salut
et voilà le lien je sais pas
fait c'est de refuser un champignon
d'ailleurs bouzat question de gironde
entre 3 je crois une explication à nous
fournir
je commence à bien aimer les noirs ici
peut-être je vois pas trop comment
défoncé 4 en fait sur cavaliers à 5
peut-être que dis je m'en fous je rentre
avec ma tour c'est possible tel qu'il a
raison de s'en [ __ ] cinq tours david
ayer chiant même si on attaque le
cavalier optique et la d8 à leurs
critiques bien juste fou et sept sur
tour de vis qui est très fort natoora
pas de gaz elle peut pas maintenir se
maintenir dans la vie de sa branche elle
fait tant de 8 est très mauvais ça lui
va lyon
gagner comme prévu et donc 19 qui prend
l'ascendant mais ça reste complexe
les blancs ou caen 3-2 assez intéressant
à négocier tandis que le 4 contre 2 ici
est assez long à se mettre en marche
mais leur principal avantage réside en
la paire de fou qui commence petit à
petit à s'activer se fout 1,8 peut enfin
quitter la défense se passe s'il deux
pions et du coup se met dans une belle
diagonale menacé fou prend 1,3 suivis de
cavaliers pros 25 arjel hall en
difficulté après les biens autant avoir
chedjou des petits coups pratique ici
avec les plans je ne m'entraîne pas de
risque salut des gal luce galax us plus
tôt
non plus sérieusement maintenant je fais
des bleus ce surtout je fais un peu de
exo tactique de tan tan tan mai mais
c'est tout ce soit on va perdre la
roumanie effectivement ça un risque
d'attirer pas mal de deux jours
habituels en spectateur à part si vous
voulez jouer en regardant en regardant
maxime qu'on chrétienne vous pouvez
faire une simultanée avec votre cerveau
[Musique]
je crois que le match est important pour
france roumanie way pour le maintien je
sais pas si je jouerai non plus haut
ce temps la ddcs a gagné un deuxième
pion est assez serein
larry va pas descendre trop bas la
pendule juste faire attention quand même
pas perdre risque de la passe que
quelques cheveux blancs sont plus
avancées et surveille change et au caire
6 cavaliers ce que vous jouez un petit
peu d'ailleurs avec la team france ou
pas le format ont plein de jouets de
bullet 2010 de rapides alors parti qui
pendant ce temps a basculé drastiquement
vacant des blancs s'échange qui avait
l'air assez naturel ont fait que deux
cavaliers pour les noirs le problème
c'est que l'on s'est fixés le purger
sept surclasse noir même sur l'adoption
de plus ici sont complètement obsolète
et du coup le roi blanc arrive plus vite
court plus vite et le pur objet est
inarrêtable au fait de cette finale de
fou à la base avec deux plombes plus bas
à perdre pour 10 10 c'est un peu dur
j'ai plutôt fait une très bonne partie
mais mais le pion s'est parlé
physique et du coup des 10 qui
abandonnent il a juste pris une mauvaise
décision et ça a suffi que c'est une
décision qui avait l'air assez assez
logique mais s'est fixée un pion sur la
mauvaise couleur on a une partie entre
4h et un ami suisse reda wood délit et
c'est la grosse perf l'a peut-être qu'à
l'âge qui accable 7 comprend de plus ici
google anglaise où je veux dire il est
un peu tendu le bâton se passaient
plutôt bien et qui secoue la tête je
vais avoir je sais pas je pense qu'il a
dû anticiper cavaliers prend plus ou
moins après nouveau b3 et ça c'est
l'accident
au fond sénoufo glouton là et il a perdu
deux pièces d'un coup parce que ce qu'il
est capable avec une tour d' est de
moins de s'en sortir ici ganache les
récupérer une pièce à oued à motegi qui
s'est montré comme un petit peu gêné
arrivait culpabiliser a rendu une faut
déjà plus qu'une pièce de moins sous qui
est un peu enfermé avec la différence
alors ça semble retournable à mais je
suis appelé je suis appelé sur manu qui
peut-être en train de gagner une partie
il faut pas rater ça autre hongre idec
aux rebelles
j'ai bien mais j'ai peur que du coup
maintenant ça tourne j'ai bien peur que
ça tombe parce que la position a quand
même l'air compliqué
[Musique]
très compliqué la même dame s'est vite
elle a plus ou moins forcé parce qu'on a
un peu toutes nos pièces emprise ici
qu'avec les noirs et le problème c'est
que toutes nos pièces se défendent les
unes les autres et généralement là c'est
comme un château de cartes
tout peut s'écrouler et donc donc manu
qui va aligner une pièce qui avait tout
calculé ces permis de nous appeler
tranquillement et je pense qu'il suffit
d'échanger les dames de ramasser le
cavalier enfin tellement d'émotion que
j'ai perdu pour la première victoire de
manu peut-être la main chez vous c'est
encore mieux du groupe vous cavaliers
comme il doit tout pour sortir
immédiatement six mois après à 3 aura
bien du mal c'est l'enfer madame x qu'il
a joué une finale 4 pions contre deux
cavaliers sas l'original ça a donné quoi
du coup quatre pions de l'allier gobain
ses avocats que les quatre qu'on veut
pas de faire mater normalement ça dépend
ce qu'ils sont liés ou pas quand même
pour avoir des chances de gains et a pu
en gagner c'est beau les cavaliers
renvoya l'écurie face à aux petits
soldats alors manu key à un cavalier de
plus en plus en plus une meilleure
structure des pieds de s'activent ils
passent par là pourquoi pas j'aurais
pris la route principale perso mais
s'ils ne se perd dans les petites routes
de montagne sinueuse avec sa tour
pourquoi pas de se permettre à la marge
et par couple je pense que tout rejet 4
nécessaires au g3 on sert pas à grand
chose quand même bien de revenir là la
wii se passe des trucs à savoir plus tôt
ll dabou il ya une faiblesse va nu pieds
bien au temps tous les voyants sont au
vert
je ne vois pas comment le joueur
français pour alléger les cjs est parti
même le four ashes existe il a ce mérite
et c c'est tout rien d'autre qui
existait trop chers les péages c'est que
les péages ne devrait pas être gratuit
cette période justement les
approvisionneurs bientôt est gratuit en
espagne j'ai pris partout à l'autoroute
du groupe en france pas que ce soit
encore d'actualité
malheureusement
ça continue de bien se passer à part une
déconnexion manu pas trop comment tu
pourrais perdre cette partie hongrie doc
devait pas être le premier à tomber en
direct sous les coups de manu on
comprend jeu
ouais je vois pas aucun moyen une astuce
rien du tout la juste trop de retard
matériel son tour n'a pas de cavalier
avec les noirs seraient très heureux
d'avoir un cavalier ici pour essayer de
faire une fourchette donc fait vraiment
vraiment vilain du pouce aux rôles
compresseur il profite de son moment il
ya trois pions passé lié mais ça y est
j'ai vu le monde dans lequel ils
pourraient perdre celui où il prendrait
un tour prend b2 mais faudra moins faire
exprès il peut tout faire dans cette
position
papa
votre film ont gagné le fou il fait dame
prend son temps iam attendant manuel est
ouvert 7 oui tempo il n'a pas tremblé et
sayed a conjuré le mauvais sort c'était
une victoire sur une belle victoire à
c'était propre
c'était prendre grosse partie de manu
condé condoléances aux canards du coup
ils partiraient qui va se terminer
pas très intéressante la dja le cavalier
peluche
là je tombe sur un superbe roi on lâche
4 qu'est ce qui se passe aux grecs
d'échec
mon cul ma taille mais il espère
j'espère que ça va être suffisant ici
dracula sentiers et joyeuse pas que
poutine a tort parce qu'ils étaient
partis à la chasse aux oeufs dans le
jardin ce matin l'a bien senti écoute
c'était un peu la démonstration de ton
talent au direct merci de l'esg à
l'action
petite dame d'amour est pour greg et
s'arrêtent forcément insuffisant
il abandonne il anticipe changé d'âme ou
même la prise de la demande un coût et
une option valable aussi on a barbarians
qui caracole en tête et on n'a pas
encore vu jouer
alors on essaie de le voir en action
contre books in a tort un joueur
allemand qui est voulu essayer de
contester la suprématie tricolore ici
mais a priori c'est pas pour aujourd'hui
parce que barbarians a l'air d'avoir une
tour de plus regarde avoir une tour de
plus pour une qualité une qualité c'est
un peu difficile de compter les pièces
bouge et beaucoup d'informations à
digérer pour mon cerveau salut piotr a
suivi la messe en direct
chassez le chocolat sur la table mais
c'est beaucoup trop facile là du coup la
personne
cachez le chocolat chez toi ou pin à
tort puisque de le cacher la veille au
soir et personne n'a oublié le bateau
quand tu te réveilles bon je retire un
peu ce que j'ai dit dans cette partie
c'est pas si facile en fait pour
barbarian la grèce à kayes et aidé
avance me fous et puissant mais les
tours s'activent les seurrois pourrait
se retrouver en danger en fou et catella
je dois tout prix empêcher la deuxième
tour de le pénétrer sa position
ranger deux tours 3 h 2 ça devient
dangereux devient très dangereux pour
notre leader mais un jeune français
barbarian est mise en difficulté
f1 - gp de france et roi va être très
dangereuse fouet dominant impose un
petit peu ça loire alors cet échec juste
perd la partie rock ou merci beaucoup
sa force les changes d'une tour est
alors typiquement quand on a tout refait
contre deux tours n'a jamais envie
d'échanger tout restantes avec les avec
les noirs parce que du coup on a plus de
pièces capable de se déplacer en
horizontal ou vertical et latour adverse
devient surpuissante
elle va encaisser des pions
tranquillement ne vous sert plus à rien
très très grave et avoir des noirs de
jouer tout rachat notre tour 3 et la
seconde rangée suisses mangent et b2 et
d'envoyer le français est ici je pense
que c'était très dur en pratique pour
les blancs le fou juste est supérieure à
la tour ici mais on va pas s'en plaindre
le craquage du noir allemand et du coup
barbarian devrait continuer son échappée
même s'il faut encore payer mais il va
manger c'est ça la mode dont ses fils y
mange un nouveau pion
la pongiste et 4 il va manger b4 ou f5
tout cas ça gagne très facilement
maintenant le futur tube toujours très
chaleureux
vous avez laissé de tous les deux la
dame en prison un coup bon c'est à se
poser des questions je joue pas à charge
shozna créés par ordinateur
à quoi vous pouvez alors
et part variable ou faire une dame au
choix il peut tout faire et si tout cas
il y aura fait preuve d'une excellente
technique toi même c'est très bien joué
le couple fou generator si peu mauvais
perdant mais ici je veux lever à bord
dont c'était dû mater avec deux dames
réponse de barbarian et oui ils
continuent de douter punchy natta a eu
de suspense quand même dans cette forme
parti mais la technique de l'escalier
parfaitement maîtrisée par le joueur
français
où va-t-on rebondir chez marques ou des
premiers entre tryphon tryphon tournesol
il a le petit avatar du coup et risque
de faire beaucoup d'ailleurs
d'étourderie pas en tout cas il a dû
offertes par cette position est que les
blancs marques ou des premiers est ici
en position de force
tuga rien il peut bouger la farfouille 3
pouces et son pull vert dames 2 3 y a
pas de mauvais coup dans le genre de
position le roi est parfaitement safe
c'est écrasant à tel point que tryphon
abandonne
on n'aura pas pu trop voit partout des
premiers en action n'a pas vu tout à
l'heure si kalach il avait sauvé les
meubles et toujours pas de cas là je
vais montrer déçus n'y arrive pas
n'arrive pas il ya quand même au foot +
on va l'abandonner là-bas joie de kalach
nous intéresse pas qui je ne suis pas
allé voir là julien la lame qui a les
blancs contre toupinou destroyer topi
nous deux et trois heures déjà il
annonce la couleur avec son pseudo
ils envoient le plus rage dans
l'ouverture et ça fait réfléchir julien
ou g5 la tâche 3 va être la bonne
réaction ici pour les douars moi
j'aurais plutôt bien joué à trois avec
les blancs au fixe espion un petit peu
faible -4
c'est pas
lauren fait place à long terme toute
façon donc de pas hésité à sacrifier moi
je pense toujours à je crois pas c'est
la partie la donne et on fout de deux
cases noires ok pourquoi pas mais j'aime
pas trop la position blanche et un peu
des trous cavaliers 4 tab à 5 ou 6 et un
gros problème le pion à a2 et très
faible grand roc était un peu ambitieux
ici dans le gros problème chance et de
l'angola n'a pas le temps de mettre
notre four 2 3 layada berthold label 5
c'est le prix dont dame b1 est réparable
le seul coup c'est de donner du matériel
bonjour d'amd 3ème tour est-ce qu'il va
le voir la rater ou pino qui a rappé
bourguignon il n'a encore très bien ce
fait plaisir fou 3 à 3 et que vous vous
revoir n'a été un petit peu
le kamikaze est ici laroquais à côté
cimetière
julien les cavaliers pros c3 si on
reprend ses maths c'est cloud est sous
contrôle
d'ici peu la bouquerie sur se sacrifier
tout la boucherie sur ce roi blanc mais
vous conclurez l'aï ratée comme il est
passé par là pas les choix les plus
précieux de tous pinault il a sacrifié
du matériel donc maintenant ça c'est
joli c'est de ramener cette tour cette
tour où je n'ai pas du tout pensé belle
manoeuvre de tout pinault est ce qui va
mettre et au péno damas deux à un
prometteur damas d'être très prometteur
ici et oui j'allais vous prend à 3 même
d'un point à trois en fait toutes les
tactiques marché
mais pour chambrer un peu pas si tu peut
sacrifier la dame ou d'en sacrifier la
darwin c'est beaucoup plus appréciable
alors damas deux dames à deux menaces
dame ces deux connaissent tomber un but
d'un stoppeur menace menace tous donc là
c'est imparable
donc je suis bien je suis un peu
abandonnés ici à sa grosse avons été de
faire le con rock notamment il a donné
son adresse un adversaire sondages cela
dit très bien je vais te battais il a
tout sacrifié tout envoyé il a eu raison
c'est jessica active elle est le roi des
blancs n'a pas du tout participé à la
partie et lui prend son temps on va
chercher notre parti voilà il abandonne
l'abandonnent est le parti qui débute
entre eux cb 33 donc cep cpe toujours
pas contre j
eh oui l'airé de confinement et prend
l'espace directement un allèle dame vois
pas la raison qui va gagnants qui ont en
fait très vite déjà il ya un petit peu
atypique ici à jiji dès l'ouverture avec
les noirs qui a été l'erreur de ces 2,7
à l'erreur typiquement s'est fait
refouler 5 faire échec pour faire échec
ça ne sert à rien vraiment avoir un but
derrière n'est pas à la boxe comparer
les coûts à la fin le nombre d'échecs
ici pour se départager toute façon donc
cet échec permet justement de gagner des
tempos c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé à chaque coup il perd un thème ou
ex nous faut donc juste sortez vos
cassure des cases plus plus naturel mons
et 4 ça se passera mieux ça raconte t il
à 100 millions - ok il va quand même
essayer de se battre pas fini
c'est pas fini
c'est difficile difficile qu'il avait
des deux voies jouets dessin qui se font
en betteraves à se retrouver
complètement fermée c'est de le
ressusciter comme ça mais c'est
compliqué très compliqué pour les blu
ray cette position le show perdu
centrale fait cruellement défaut
cavalier f4 c'est pas très naturel non
plus comme les pièces un petit
embouteillage ici aujourd'hui à chis or
c'est fou prend et ça c'est assez malin
il est certainement menacé de gagner une
pièce à bourdonner jj pour l'instant kg
et serein ça lui prend son temps il a
raison le futur qui n'a pas mis ses
lentilles aujourd'hui lancé existe la
variante perceval là le jeu des trois
échecs ou cassation le premier qui
réussit à faire trois échecs griller la
partie c'est très simple comme règle
c'est pas si facile parce que tu peux te
précipiter vers deux échecs d'entrée
pour sacrifier du matériel je vous coupe
les coulisses à du matériel au moins tu
seras dominé n'arrivera jamais donné le
troisième échec
c'est un jeu intéressant raté gicm ans
vous pouvez essayer les trois échecs
forcément fixer un nombre en fait parce
que ces échecs illimité va celui à la
fin qui est sur le point de mater va
jamais matté faire que des échecs pour
dépasser son adversaire de manière
certaine ouais
après tu deviendrais gagnant sinon
exactement gg c'est pour ça que le
nombre 3 a été choisi en général est 5
c'est beaucoup un tutu seras-tu verra où
un pote avec qui joue à cette variante
et essaiera 3tera à sa banque
parce que du coup ça c'est un pièce
complètement votre manière de jouer on
sait qu'on doit pas être miro d'échec le
pays perd attention évidemment on va pas
va pas se prendre un fou les cinq échecs
par exemple avec les noirs de
l'ouverture sur le d'espagnol ou autre
chose
ok et du coup vous arriver facilement à
3 et benji continue le mode rouleau
compresseur ces deux fous sont
prédominants il sert même pas deux de
ses pièces ici je crois que c'est que f3
même le 3
la trouée complètement la position
blanche el-assad qui craquent sous la
pression le cavalier oublié par les
noirs il prend un pion qui est protégé
beaucoup trop de fois sa sortie de
comptage de calcul pour sepp c'est
difficile difficile aussi peut-être ça
va un peu vite cette cadence
donc on va les cj tranquillement
terminer le travail avec toutes ses plus
de plus j'arrive pile sur un bateau hb
mattei si notre position oui et pas
grand chose à faire
ce conte
adrait pas un petit coup de man u en
cachette sans lui dire au revoir
manu qui a les noirs contre euro d'avs
gros dave peut-être c'est plus élégant à
tous et j'essaie de te faire gagner le
tir la prochaine regarde manu après
j'essaie de te faire gagner 5 960 el
papa pinguins à moi aussi je trouve ça
plutôt sympa plus lucratif en tout cas
le pit la théorie vous réfléchissez le
premier cours pas ça ne plaît et je te
porte bonheur la prochaine mouture
promis voici en fait on vérifie si le
sort est bien conjurer à savoir si manu
peut gagner sans nous le dire
une épave orient les mieux classés son
adversaire qui est un peu en difficulté
dans cet endroit n'a pas encore marqué
de points il va jouer une finale tu as
vu qu'il était une grosse technique manu
il l'a démontré la partie d'avant et les
quand même mieux dans cette position il
ya un gros avantage des espaces ll dame
ces pièces sont plus harmonieuses
je me certainement un 4 à 3 des choses
comme ça
retour à l'air force est ici se défaire
de cette diagonale
il reste 35 minutes sarrazin si tu veux
le lien se faire quelques parties
libre à toi ben du cac en bits et le
plonger 5
le beau jeu c'est très bien joué est-ce
que du coup tomber la pression sur ce
cavalier et a pas de défense food est un
cas l'air à première vue de sauver un
peu la faire à cause de tout reprendre
et un va te tais la tour et derrière
c'est la double attaque et au final
n'aura gagné une pièce avec les noirs
donc adresse pollution ici pour les
blancs là pas de solution et gros dave
qui est ce que vous trouvez une c'est
normal mais dans tous les cas il devrait
perdre une pièce ayasse et 4 mais parle
pas vu mais ça va juste retardé le
problème va manger ses cartes avec
lecavalier il le joue d'ailleurs et
procès quatre n'a pas le temps fait de
s'extirper de cette à mathias la ride et
dans le talent c'est le confinement à
tous répond je pense qu'elle encore
moins - n'est-ce pas ce que nous a dit
1 4 seydou un jouet ai pas pensé à
quatre intermédiaires et maintenant il
menace qu on a dit aux condéens n'y a
pas de défense peut jouer d'ailleurs
tout prendre il s'y met y aura prises en
c4 qui l'attend pour commencer par bon
j'ai ouvert à la colla nous pensons
toujours ici tous gagnent toutes façons
c'est écrasant pour le noir il récuse
cette décision tout à fait respectable
et maintenant tout reprendre un tour à
deux tours
je suis un citoyen s'était pas montré
ses ailes mais ok ça reste pas mal avec
les blu c'est la souffrance commission
tout aussi à l'essai de fuir on sent
qu'il veut sortir de l'écran petit à
petit ils se replacent ont pas chassés
on foule court mais malheureusement n'a
pas droit de cité à pecq soit la
paroisse de sortie on n'a pas l'aura de
s'échapper
du coup il va juste tous faire manger
c'est trop et veut c'est la
démonstration de value leur état de
grâce depuis depuis qu'on l'a vu en
direct veut aller chercher les trois
fois plus qu'annoncé notre pioncer ya
pas de carnac et ici on prend vraiment
rien la tour peut même pas aller menacer
sur elle cette situation n'aura
extrêmement pérenne et un petit à petit
échec
il a parlé d'un pas vraiment de maths du
courant vert ou le principe et ses
quatre systèmes de l'avion radar du
symat non c'est le plus simple
g6 pourquoi pas l'actif sa dernière
pièce qui jouait pas
le cavalier complètement dominé ici y'a
pas de case par rémi roger un homme à
lui très près et ne laisser aucun
contrôle de son adversaire c'est
vraiment difficile pour gros dave
l'établé le fond en g2 finir en beauté
elle voulait mater comme ça ça aurait
été assez joli on reste dans le thème du
matin à l'étouffée le rapace aura pas
fini je crois va juste faire une dame
avec notre plan b
a priori si changer des pièces est aussi
faux gagne ou on gagne pour banlieue on
va après le garder un petit est jusqu'au
bout pour autant je commence à chercher
le futur qui veut qu'on lui porte
bonheur
est ce qu'il est en train de jouer
dessus de faire déjà l'instant je ne
vois pas une turpitude cure est ce qu il
deux parties tu as joué contre jj 2
jours 9 points chacun et on compte sur
bas du pont pour finir le plus vite
possible son pion et à deux cases de
promotion est tombé 1 par exemple
histoire de pas le pion à lille va quand
même arrêter le pion fait durer le
plaisir un petit peu on peut lui faire
confiance c'est complètement terminée b2
si on m'en fait d'armes n'en a plus qu à
déloger ce cavalier c'est pas si
difficile où ils peuvent perdre à
monsieur pas embêtés et comme ça voilà
la dernière pièce plonge disparaître on
peut arrêter là pour manu on sait qui va
essayer et voir si on peut sauver aidant
à redon d'arriver trop tard
seul pour sauver le soldat du futur va
essayer de trouver du coup une partie
des futures du début va se lancer là
abandonné 1 pile l'a senti il a senti
qu'on arrive et il abandonnait mettre
autant en avion
on utilise un pro
môssieur alors tu te tuerais ce que ça
sera long ce sera perdre une partie du
début tu dur avec les blancs contre galy
et qui est le petit drapeau marocain
alors ça ressemble bien les spiritueux
ce coup deux à quatre élite
je ne connais pas tu test lab hôtesses
marques ou des premiers et ben écoute
mais attend impatiemment son retour
salut avec à chibi on vas tu arrives
pour la dernière demi-heure et pour la
mission porte-bonheur en vertu du rdda
réussi à des poisses manu qui m'attend
gagnent toutes ses parties de manière
magistrale
ouah ouah si il en est de même pour tutu
arthur qu'à une petite faiblesse à
essayer de titiller en 1600 musicale
plus de fous de quatre planches auraient
été bien utiles un jour de position
genre d'option il faut quand même très
égard et que les blancs n'a jamais envie
de manger
évidemment faire attention à la
fourchette
peut-être que même les noirs sont
légèrement mieux maintenant b3 était pas
forcément nécessaire pour tous deux
furent quoi un petit peu trop neutre à
mon goût d'aller blanc ici wright
les cavaliers de on se retire la
fermeture du centre était pas non plus
obligatoire ici et oui effectivement
elle catchy super soirée hier vous avez
tous été très très jeune mais espère le
même résultat ce soir pour la finale il
y a
sur double attaque et fourchettes ici un
petit peu et j'appelle un absence de
débat ça kevin s'achète une bête de
garde ordinateur a priori et ce soir
c'était pour fab five génère pour que
fab qui joue à football manager sans lag
est content c'est une belle cause
tout aussi noble que médecins sans
frontières ou que décupler vos dons
alors tout genre pendant ce temps là tu
te jure ce porte plutôt bien
il a un peu l'initiative allèles dames
avec la colonne à la tour qui va rentrer
peut-être on essaie de nous ça reste
solide côté noir avant les vrais jouets
c3 c4 je sais pas casser ce centre
cavaliers ou pas grand chose ici
une position pas forcément facile à
jouer des deux côtés d'ailleurs je
trouve ça manque un peu de 10 ha voilà
attacks paroisse au bar des canarias ses
six balles et farah vocabulaire espagnol
n'a guère évolué como estas c'est à peu
près tout ce que chez dia mais je le dis
bien
enfin il paraît c'est ça vous donne à
tort augmenter un petit peu le budget de
la bce sur fn parce que c'est un peu
difficile a priori pour l'instant balle
et si vous allez en espagne en dit balle
et ça marche à tous les coups
mon astuce du jour là les balles et une
tape sur l'épaule ça marche aussi
baltard n'est pas être trop répétitif
alors tu as elle continue quant à elle
de mettre la pression
il a pris la possession total de la
colonne à il fait un bon travail en
stratégiques pendant que l'union
complètement alors prouver à la base qui
s'est juste pour lui porter bonheur
après faut encore gagner la partie ça
reste difficile parce que côté côté de
galles et on est hyper solide en défense
ça le jeu en fond de court mais tutu
rengaine il
angèle tour pourquoi pas je vois encore
patrons comment il va percer cette
muraille pour l'instant il est
clairement mieux mais la seule faiblesse
c b6 et on peut le surprotéger avec la
noire palmarès je vais essayer on a
touché les poteaux en 1976 à écoute tu
retires à sa femme à son prochain traîne
je pense qu'il sera très heureux de
cette remarque est ce qu'on pourrait pas
me la carie angers si si si c'est
difficile de le stabiliser
j'ai essayé d'échanger des pièges
commence avec les avec les noirs on peut
toujours le du h4 mais bon bien sûr un
tour à 6 et doubler sur la colonne a à
priori c'est le plan le plus simple pour
toitures à l'étude sur 45 secondes pour
tuture sûr qu'ils nous écoutent et torah
5 tuture juste pour vérifier quand vous
fois cinq peut-être a décidé de créer un
fonds bat ses protégés sur qui consolide
son roi il a le temps c'est une position
très lente
tout est fermé du coup ça veut dire
qu'on a le tempérament de faire des
manoeuvres ici mais il a quand même du
mal à progresser alors je dessins que
c'est osé sûr qu'il veut faire damas
vite échec et il n'y aura pas la partie
sur le show mais sans filtre s'il arrive
à doubler sur la 7ème tour il sera très
très bien et avec les droits ou jouent
en voie de fermeture éclair ferme tout
ferme la boutique pour galy et ali qui
respectent les consignes de confinement
à la perfection août
mine est ouverte on qu'un pion donc je
peux manger un autre en diagonale n'a
que des visées à vis de bloquer mes
futurs d'esprit un petit peu plus libre
apparemment un petit peut se révéler ici
commence quand même être très actif dans
le futur la position noir se fissure
allèles dame allait le roi alors moi
perso je fais pas de moto frank zappa le
soleil me donne d'autres envies c'est à
l'usiné jean homme du match
le tueur il peut envoyer ses pièces
n'hésite pas le tout sur là pour faire
le bouge tout à gagner et à rompre la
malédiction bien et voilà ça y est ils
touchent la victoire du doigt un
adversaire qui a craqué bâton et surtout
au bon jeu tout à perpète le royal à
brides
du coup ça a l'air de se vérifier un le
direct qui porte bonheur ou joueurs
qu'ils demandent
n'hésitez pas mange tous les pions hors
jeu pas très heureux de cette décision
traduit ici avant j'aurais pas hésité à
échanger une tour nous avons craint plus
rien du tout se crée des problèmes pour
rien là il donne son cavalier pour
éviter à la dap de rentrer et il est
champion
il revient à la raison mais s'est fait
une petite frayeur vers le futur avec
cette colonne f heureusement pour lui la
finale est écrasante
une marée de pions ça ne suffit pas il
n'en manger encore d'autres à bissau
lire le tueur a priori ici il refuse la
changer tour alors son pion au bbq bolt
court est très très vite
ça change pas la face du monde d'accord
non c'est quasiment au fond tant j'ai
envie de dire de gagner pour les blancs
suffit d'avancer ses pions
là par contre je pourrais pas on est
beaucoup trop long et le futur il ya
bien manger des pions aps la justin
theroux d'arménie veut tout manger sont
que n'aime pas quand il reste un pion
sur l'échiquier
ça fait tâche bah bravo bravo le futur
ça a été long mais bellevarde
stratégique pas regardé gagner c'est
barbare yade qui caracole en tête avec
17 me sur 18
on va aller faire un tour à l'orgue à
lyon vient bien de regarder peut-être la
partie d'avant hongrie la commission
essaie de trouver des plats peut-être
qu'on a moins vu c'est la fin
alors on à marcy psycho j'allais blanc
contre elle car la table et marcy chico
qui a perdu une pièce ce qui s'est passé
ah oui et cavalcades proches et saint
calais où l'on voit les humeurs
sympathique pour marc simard site si com
m j'ai envie de dire c'était un petit
peu audacieux sacrifice de pièces les
compensations ne saute pas aux yeux
maintenant il faut qu'attaquer être
marcy commence un peu à regretter son
choix ici c'est trop tard attention
cette dame aura changé d'un poil vite se
faire enfermer et l'arrêt
la taille des changes la pièce tu sais
le plus sain la pièce de plus n'a pas
besoin de chercher des coups incroyables
des combinaisons juste on les change
tout et on finit avec la pièce d' avance
jacques rogge de chaque côté donc les
plans et ses droits quel côté opposé en
désespoir de cause saluer opère et salue
plus aux crocs et ouais c'est de
l'optimisme au lac la rebond à
l'optimisme optimiste
marcy marsick un peu à court de solution
qui prend son temps
je crains que le mal de soif et les
blancs dans cette plus la dame peut
s'infiltrer oms et 2 à l'empêchera
grandemange rap et de mangera ces trois
opus on empêche aussi le petit roanne
sur dame ces deux causes du cavalier d2
qui se retrouve vraiment l'air du
ku'damm cde a l'air très puissant ici
pour les pour le noir pour accélérer un
peu tout ça peut aussi se garder notre
cavalier il ya des trous partout sur
cases blanches ont profité le rythme et
qui n'est pas très élevé dans cette
partie là c'est l'étape de plaine
osons temps ont finalement petit rock
bon pourquoi pas est un grand katembo on
va essayer quand même de faire des trucs
à cleebourg doit h4 pour ouvrir sur
achète sait-on jamais mais obtient du
pied droit peuvent g can à tout moment
pour forcer les shojo dame donc initial
charles à thann à part si perd autant à
force de réfléchir devrait aller
cavaliers detroit une sur nouveaux aux
ménages donc c'est bien je vous êtes
sympas et camille détroit ils ont une
découverte derrière cavaliers pros de la
ramasser une tour accentués sont
davantage matériel et le cavalier d'être
4 3 ou 4 sur cavaliers quatre autres
attaques la dame aux cavaliers preuve de
plus précis ici bas h4
en cas d'accord un peu croient j'essaie
de trouver des idées pour les blancs ou
les accords qui a rien qui marche
mais dans un cas hypothétique où les
pièces doivent bougerait façon la salsa
de chance quoi d'autre le char n'attend
vraiment qu'il prend son tampon ils ont
les auditions derrière donc quand on
bloque un peu sur un coup pas justifié
et maintenant il va sûrement faire ce
que tu as dit peu ou prou juste pour
jouer à quatre où j'ai quatre ça marche
aussi vous forcent les changes b dames
est confiné avec une tour de plus et
c'est l'abandon l'abondon alors qu'ils
ont la voir un petit peu cela pourrait
un petit peu ça they par le tour de
magie est vite arrivé
alors 10 nov
vous avez perdu une partie gagnante à
leurs contres du bo n'a pas encore vu là
bonjour tu es là une scandinave l'école
bistrot mienne ici représentée par une
prière à voir d'où il vient et on vient
la position actuelle qui est assez
équilibré les noirs vous faire petit
rock de recomposer donc devrait avoir un
peu d'animation
même s'il est fou on disparu de
l'échiquier quand même les du goût qui
envoie cette chose s'est passée dans
l'espoir que m guillard qui réclament
poupine à tort huit pays bas à lyon tu
as beaucoup fait aujourd'hui sera
peut-être devoir poulina temps après
pour finir ce que tu continues gagné
toutes les parties et manyu pas ça la
vraie question c'est vraiment la course
les deux camps qui attaquent on voit les
pions à la dame a des droits
c'est assez chaud djamarat pourra dire
qui arrivera en premier les doigts en
l'air d'avoir une légère avance il tient
ce cavalier les bien positionnés pour
attaquer mais ça reste très indécis on
espère juste ne pas avoir de plâtrerie à
base de cavaliers qu'adam fkt des
changes de dames
là on serait très déçu on espère la
prise si du beau il est beau il est là
pour mater son adversaire évidemment va
jouer à quatre at elle peu après la
reprise le piège ce sont au bas du dam
des 5
c'est très fâché voilà un cadeau jouer
elle fait une nulle manioc qui est nul
ça passe encore les b4y c'est de cavalia
3 à ce fameux match et ce qui marche est
ce que j'ai encore la partie la partie
de nous verse une partie sur de hockey
lieu de cavaliers pros f2s que y'avait
maths je ne crois pas je crois pas et
quoi la position exacte et cavalli ton
des trois points sur cavaliers b 4
échecs pig lomé avait eu quatre c'est
pas un double échec et ip quatre échecs
et les blancs avaient option est
soutenue par les cavaliers pouvait jouer
que quatre par l échec
ça marchait pas sinon effectivement eu
ce thème de maths à l'étouffée classique
voilà ça je n'étais pas loin
le départ est de toute façon
chais pas non plus où il faut que le
carnet souvent à 3 pour ça marche quand
on fait dame bien évidemment pour forcer
la prise de la tour du cou dans tous les
cas on n'arrivait pas à faire ce match
arrivait pas bien vu il a dit non c'est
vrai et pendant ce temps là comme on
sait voler ou l'aller les bleus ont pris
de l'avant ce qui s'est passé il a joué
j'ai site ici et jouer j'ai si peu alors
peut-être là l'erreur c'est tellement
j'ai pu aurait dû continuer la course à
troyes aube et 3 s'est pas passé dans ce
genre de positions très dures à calcul
est là le roi à l'esprit la fourchette
du groupe enough is enough finalement
qui a été plus rapide dans l' attaquent
une look est pas récompensée il aurait
pu forcer les changes des dames
elle a juste perdu la sienne ou 1 pour
rien
h alors ici je pense qu'un choc c'est un
beau coup en annonçant fallait continuer
la tacc par un 3bet points et c'est bien
sûr à choquer très logique pour faire
mais peut-être que les plans ici au
récit et g600 le plus naturel et la
meilleure perspective des blaireaux
cette aide avant d'échanger les dames
mais faut pas trop parce qu'on a ce cas
là il ya un recoin de variantes
sinon j'aurais comme cavalier 5 toute
façon je démens il est sûr qu'à ce bloc
à base de g6 d'un procès 6 la position
restait compliquée ici quelques
cavaliers d'eads se bat non et ça à
jouer des deux côtés mais à chaque bien
évidemment un bien meilleur coût pour
les noirs le manger et d'ouvrir la
position de l'endroit de la position
actuelle
ça va continuer avec la femme de plus
malgré tout il arrive attaquer un peu
sans dame hugo et 19 cas plus cuisse
secondes
hélas quand même normal pour l'argent
mais aussi le manque du matériel pour
les douars malheureusement pour être
vraiment bien sur 206 foot case blanche
s'il a fait le travail
laurent blanc qui on a vu du pays mais
ok y'a pas peur ici je connais un petit
peu avec le feu je trouve en dise la
même si ça a l'air d'aller mais à chaque
fois ça joue un peu à une case à les
faire attention y'a pas eu un
[Musique]
j'ai cru pattes mais non y'a bien
matt du coup maintenant on va échanger
une tour juste se mettre à l'abri des
échecs et c'est complètement terminée
une petite frayeur quand même qu'il va
manger ce cavalier se prendre une
enfilade oui mais c'est pas grave parce
qu'on a une tour de plus à la fin
ok et lastminute j'essaie de voir poule
predator je le trouve sous le pied là
dedans je ne le vois pas la partie n'est
pas lancée ouais en fait une pièce
quelle qu'elle soit aurait fait le
travail boucraut ou le plein à temps
pour le pin à tort oui tu as il est là
il joue contre qu'à la chambre plus mais
on est déçu peaufine attends tu veux
qu'on te suivent ils sur la sicilienne
aux joutes du f4 ou de secours on n'a
pas une bombe elle cale h dim de maxime
pompiers va quand même essayer de finir
sur cette partie alors on voit que les
planches du blé noir par 12 voix elle
est là le double salaire un petit peu
longs cheveux blonds et plus directs
base de f5 jamais une bonne nouvelle
quand on doit casser son structure deux
sur le tour montjean m5 optionnellement
c'est un gros affaiblissement le fou est
quand même très mauvais ici des cinq est
faible la fois cheese un peu ci sont
noirs là en lambeaux ici
alors y avait pas de danger saint parce
que cabaye a g6 sommet mais il tente un
toute façon il n'a pas un choix à mon
nid doit trouver un moyen de défendre
cette pièce avec le noir mais ça a l'air
complètement foutu ça me saoule les
kalachs à le grand prix au moins et a
fait sept spectacles
ça fait du spectacle après tu as l'air
de bien maîtriser de mon système avec
4,4 n'a en tout cas dans cette partie ça
se passe plutôt bien c'est toi c'est
quoi à peut-être été un peu rapide ici
un jour d'alger 5-fu projet c'est sa
valeur de maths et de manière forcée au
monde sur voix prend elle avait trop
moche et ça c'était matt dire s'il faut
prolonger cette et noir ont pas le droit
de reprendre ya peu de chances que ça se
passe bien pour eux comme si leur fou
s'était transformée à la changer de
couleur d'alger 5 a été joué et la plus
aguerrie comme m6 qui peut être sauvé un
peu tout pour être noir ont géré cette
wii les trois projets 7 ici et tempo
simplement surtout recettes et les tours
à 100 ok éprise prise même qui l'a donné
c'est opiniâtre qui a complètement
craqué ici incroyable a été obligé de
reprendre la tour intermédiaire issou
vers 6h catchy la poule
nathan il s'est auto dissoute à ça c'est
terrible pour lui les oublier de manger
la touriste y réfute bon laisse pas
passer l'aubaine calage qui était
vraiment complètement foutue maintenant
il va juste renvoyé ses pions faire une
dame ça c'est incroyable ce qui s'est
passé dans cette partie où pina attend
aussi qui parlait dans le chat des piper
concentraient au niveau des tons rose à
paillettes on a dépassé les 5000 euros
je sais pas de combien exactement mais
peut pas énormément car c'était déjà une
très belle somme on espère du coup faire
aussi bien ce soir
si on regarde le foot ou simplement cac
lâche 1 à plus de 10 secondes et un
crémant ça devrait quand même pas
peut-être problème ici des dons 1er par
rapport à médecins sans frontières
beaucoup s'étaient pas parmi nous hier
soir y avait une grosse soirée avec lvl
bac pro mathieu cornède fababy kevin
c'est une espèce de coupe en demi-finale
avec un appel aux dons et ce soir ya la
finale donc n'hésite pas par contre est
au rendez vous voilà toute la clique
exactement à partir de 19h je pensais
qu'on prend l'antenne mais la finale
autres nv les bacs rose débute à 20h30
et après après la finale il y aura il y
aura une interview spéciale de maxime
qui répondra aux questions dont le chat
un petit peu sur sur comment ça s'est
passé ou candidats donc ce sera sûrement
très sympa n'hésitez pas il a fait un
sacrifice de dernière maximum pour
essayer de trop lui kevin et mais kevin
s'en est bien sorti la panique est pas
forcément évidente repousse bourgeois
aussi pensé qu' il veut nous battre
cette façon mais c'était insuffisant le
prix des bonnes décisions pratiques
qu'elle
dans cette partie et ce avec une petite
grotte aux siens de maxime évidemment ça
c'était prévu pendant la dernière minute
donc ce sera assurément d'autres
dernières parties et pin à tort au fait
il a réussi à ne pas la perdre
à savoir crémant il doit attendre une
passe fermathe et ça va jouer si c'est
bon à quelques secondes près leçon
c'était pour dire que c'est la dernière
minute ouais exactement et ghachi a
vraiment explosé à la gagnotte du coup
il reste 3 2 et le second la poupine à
tort et 20 secondes barella donc ne va
pas se faire mater ici paupiette à 500
euros effectivement paupiettes très très
généreux bouder ce groupe b d'anthologie
en full delà de la doudoune et du coup
la reine est terminée donc ici à ces cas
là je dois être déçu de ne pas avoir pu
mater et en répétant ce qu'il méritait
vraiment sur cette partie vous n'aurez
plus à un amateur 20 coups
je call me regarde et qui a gagné mais
sans surprise barbarian qui a quand même
marqué 71 points 19 ennemis sur 20 pour
barbarian comme à l'école un quasi
perfect fini de voir j'ai lol et paquito
qui complète le podium ici mais un peu
moins de monde aujourd'hui que les
arènes précédente de dimanche fait beau
n'a pas droit de sortir je ne sais pas
en tout cas
en tout cas ce soir soyez nombreux à
partir de 19h je pense je crois pas
qu'il ya un horaire au camp officiel
mais chic et ça et voyez ça au moins
pour la finale à partir de 20h30 depuis
l'interview de max derrière ce débat est
sympa ce soir et puis en début de
semaine prochaine y aura quelles villes
et rossi femmes et donc mike the bike
qui commentera avec nous profitez-en
donc merci à tous merci à marc sied
aussi on a vu une de tes parties c'est
pas qu'on reprenne les arénas king très
bientôt normalement je sais que niveau
gros tournois sur internet
on en parle beaucoup en interne mercredi
prochain déjà y avoir un gros trou
abyssal avec great shoegaze zelda car
bora il y aura sûrement des arènes
l'arrêt non plus merci boulbina top
weight hadjal tracas des bars si on a vu
ça où ça arrive mais au meilleur en tout
cas merci à tous un très bientôt
soyez nombreux ce soir merci pour votre
générosité encore et continuent à
continuer comme ça pour médecins sans
frontières allez ciao ciao